For this problem, imagine that one summer you're feeling particularly adventurous
and you dig a hole straight through the center of the earth and by some miracle,
you don't end up roasting yourself in the earth's core or anything like that.
You managed to dig all the way through to the other side of the earth.
And to celebrate the completion of your big summer project,
you decide to leap dramatically into your tunnel to head towards the other side of the earth.
Now, it turns out if you were to do this, you would oscillate back and forth
between the earth's surface on this side and the earth's surface on this side,
and lo and behold and turns out that this motion through the earth's core
is actually simple harmonic motion.
To see why this is simple harmonic motion,
we're going to have to investigate what gravity is like within the earth.
We know what it's like above the earth, but what's it like inside the earth.
It turns out that the force of gravity within the earth's surface is equal to gm/rer.
You're distance away from the center of the earth which I'm calling r here.
Now, it's possible to derive this equation from scratch but the derivation is quite complicated,
so I'm not going to do it here but we should discuss that on the forums.
The key thing we see about this equation is that the force grows proportionally
with the distance away from the center of the earth and where we had seen this before?
Well, it looks exactly like Hooke's Law which says that the force, a spring pulls on an object
is equal to the spring constant times it's displacement away from the center.
This equation for the force of a spring looks just like this equation
for the force of gravity within the earth's surface except instead of x, we used r
and instead of K, we have gm over the radius of the earth.
Okay, now that you know how gravity scales within the earth,
I want you to tell me what's the period of this simple harmonic motion.
How long does it take for you to return to your original starting point, once you jumped in the earth
completing one complete cycle here and put your answer in minutes
and for this problem you should use 10 m/sec² for g,
and you should use 6400 km for the radius of the earth--good luck!